[Musique]
annulé l'année dernière à cause du coc
vite 19 le salon international de
l'agriculture se tiendra cette année du
26 février au 6 mars plusieurs
producteurs yvelinois et seront présents
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
installé depuis 1978 à orgeval la maison
folie mais s'étend sur 27 hectares
véritable histoire de famille thomas
élite de l'exploitation de ses parents
en 2005 notre ferme a été créée par mes
parents en 1978 ils sont arrivés ici il
y avait seulement
seulement des chaumes de blaison tout
bâti donc les bâtiments les serres et
ils sont implantés les vergers et puis
développer la culture du maraîchage sur
le plateau d à l'heure la famille y
cultive uniquement des fruits et des
légumes de saison les produits sont
récoltés et vendu le jour même c'est qui
permet d'assurer aux clients leur
fraîcheur donc là l'hiver en fait radis
salades et match et puis on saison bas
tout ce qui est courgettes tomates
aubergines poivrons et donc idem oui il
ya de la série de concours actuellement
de la bataille à la bahia de la petite
salade qui sera pour le mois de mars et
shiva la préparer la terre on mettra de
la courgette à début mars autre point
important pour la maison la pratique
d'une agriculture raisonnée afin de
restreindre son impact sur
l'environnement l'entreprise limite ses
apports en engrais et protection
chimique et utilise plutôt des méthodes
naturelles pour lutter contre les
nuisibles nos pratiques culturales sont
basés sur l'agriculture raisonnée donc
on utilise un maximum de lutte
biologique on va par exemple dans les
tunnels introduire des prédateurs pour
contrer les populations de ravageurs
vous voyez là par exemple on est sur un
paillage donc ça nous permet de pas
faire de désherbants et puis en même
temps on a une charrette qui ne touchent
pas le sol donc du coup on a pas de
développement de maladies donc on arrive
à conduire une bataille a sans aucun
traitement la maison folie se rendra au
salon de l'agriculture pour réaliser une
dégustation de jus maison avec le grand
public et faire connaître sans savoir
faire on sera présent sur deux jours on
fera déguster nos jus de pomme on prend
on pourra aussi également vendre notre
production des pommes des conserves
on essaiera de se faire connaître et
puis pourquoi pas de gagner quelques
clients c'est la cinquième fois que
l'exploitation sera un salon de
l'agriculture c'est une belle vitrine
pour nous puis c'est important je pense
en ile-de-france de montrer qu'il ya une
vraie production et paul clients s'ils
souhaitent manger local il ya de quoi
faire la maison pogné propose à la vente
80 variétés de fruits et légumes
différents
[Musique]